so i got a question for you if i were to
ask you how many seconds or minutes can
you hold your breath
underwater what would you say i myself a
couple years ago were in cancun and i
got all these guys
were around the pool and we're like how
long can you do it one guy does a 42
seconds
how long can you do it one lady a
crystal does it a minute and six seconds
another guy how long can you do it
he comes and does it a minute 30 seconds
guy from puerto rico ricardo
and today my guest owns the world record
for holding his breath underwater you
know what record it is you know you're
ready for the time
he broke his own record of 2411.
the world record for holding your breath
underwater he holds
24 minutes and 33 seconds nearly a half
hour
he helped this actually actually
actually it's a 37 because the guinness
uh approved me uh there is a three
uh stop watch yes on a different
on a different position and they say
uh okay we will take a middle of it and
middle of it
it's because it was five different
watches
yeah and if you know what i mean it's it
could be a mistake
sometimes they think uh when you start
the bubble they have to
start the the clock uh the most of them
started at the moment i pull up my uh
oxygen and they started at that moment
in that moment it now it's officially on
their page
and i hope uh in their book it will be
37. i tell you what i hope they're
watching this guinness you better get
your act together it's 24
37 not 24 33 and and yes
again you're a former bodybuilder
special forces stunt man
and you were recognized as you did you
did your homework
you didn't saw your video i saw you're
pretty tall by the way you're a tall
bodybuilder you're not short
yeah and uh and you have some four yeah
that's pretty tall so so walk me back
take me back through you know 24 minutes
and you said you've been only diving for
uh for seven years
how do you go from i mean where were you
at seven years ago holding your breath
to work your way up to 24 minutes and 37
seconds
it's it's it's a funny story because i
was
semi-professional basketball player okay
then i had a back surgery
a long time ago and uh but
i am the the person i have to train
no matter what if we are if we are doing
i can put uh the lots of cars
uh on the parking this side is red
this side is yellow this side is blue i
have to do
something if you know what i mean so i
started with the bodybuilding
and i i kind of joined in bodybuilding
except one thing but you will
you'll find that kind of funny
the only thing i hate it is being on a
stage
really why is that yes i i i'm telling
you i have no problem with
nudicity if you know what i mean i i was
most of the time when i was younger
i for for a bet i took my clothes off in
a in a
disco club or something like that and i
had a problem with the bodyguards
and things like that and uh but i have
no dead problem but i have a problem
if i am in a swimsuit and uh
10 guys and uh challenges they have to
decide
how good i am and this is the part where
i don't feel
comfortable if you if you understand my
point
this is just visual point you have to be
you have to smile you have to practice
the position you have to seven uh
part of position you have to show them
and uh
i was training uh 24 7
3 365 days a year if you know what i
mean
but the most important thing is to
prepare yourself for pausing
and i didn't count on that if you know
what i mean
and when the start that the composite
competition start
i was failed i never do the
i was the first favorite
for winning a gold medal if you know
what i mean because i was looking
let's say good let's say better than the
others but on a stage
i was just like oh oh
and i'm finished because i didn't feel
comfortable i i was wearing only
a small small small small bikini if you
know what i mean
and i said no this is not good for me
this i i don't feel comfortable
i really like to train i really like the
routine
you have to wake up at five o'clock in
the morning you have to eat
20 eggs you have to eat three or four
uh pounds of
chicken meat you have to eat vegetables
you have to go to sleep
earlier and at the same moment
uh i've got my daughter and we have we
understood that we we will have lots of
lots of problem with her because she was
very she was born with brain damage okay
you didn't know that no i didn't know
that she was born autistic okay you
raise money
yeah yeah before that but but before
that
we have to uh learn her how to walk
and we were practicing that for more
than three years
six hours a day your wife talks about
that your wife says how much time you
put
every day teaching her to do everything
every every
blind day only in three years time
we skipped for two days
because she had a flu and in that time
when the kids with the problem with the
brain
uh you you it's not allowed
to practice with that because of con of
contraction of
the brain and things like that so you
have to stop
for instance my daughter she was
start to swim before she was started to
walk
uh really because in a water
you can do wrong movements
because it's different media yes
really really i know that because i'm uh
i'm lots of time i'm a guest in a lot of
uh university and to speak then because
she is one of the really rarest
kids that now she's walking
perfectly normally because uh if you see
the
the guy may i be honest
please if you see the kid
with a celebral paralyzed if you know
what i mean she's walking like this with
her legs like this
uh in 99 if she comes to the proper
pediatric she will be or he
will walk properly trust me
it works for all over the world but
there is a
couple of things that we have a problem
first of all
it's bloody difficult to stop loving
yourself
first of all in that moment you have to
stop loving yourself
all the things you've done you eat
shrimps you eat
uh the the best meat you uh
you drink the best malt whiskey you have
to forget about it
you have to forget about it for the rest
of your life now
the only important thing is your kid
and if you are ready to commit yourself
that
i will do six hours a day
by the way i had a good business which
were making the money
by itself so i can stay at home for six
hours a day
and practice with uh with my daughter
and
she started to walk when she was two and
a half
we we could allowed her to start to walk
much earlier but in that case we would
go
for a celebrate if you know what i mean
yes
before you put your daughter or your
child
motorically absolutely correct
up and down up and down straight
straight
back left right left up
you are not allowed to put your kid to
walk
so we were holding there her
for more than two and a half years at
the moment when
our pediatrics said okay try
to put her on her legs or your knee on
her knees
then it's time for a walk
so it's a i can say
uh like i said you have to stop loving
yourself
i know it's kind of uh
there is a two there is a sorry but i
have to say there is a two way you can
start
to believe in god and say it's a god
will
and what will happen it'll happen
don't get me wrong i don't believe in
god i believe only in my
will and one day when it's my time
to go whatever up
if you know what i mean uh heaven or
whatever uh you have to mirror in in
front of yourself
and you will say to yourself was i
good man or was i a piece of [ __ ]
if you know what i mean because for the
last 20 years
i forget about the cinema i forget about
my pleasures i forget about
especially my wife and we stuck with her
and we tried to do our best to
avoid that she is working improperly
now she is working properly but autism
it makes nothing with the
uh celebrate paralyzed if you know what
i mean it's a two different stories
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question so by the way people don't
even know your name because i haven't
even said it yet buddhism
and you are from croatia what part of
croatia are you currently in
uh zagreb is the capital city of croatia
that's where the earthquake happened
that's the earthquake 4.8 earthquake you
raise money for them
yes i raise money for them and last year
i was pronounced from
european community as a hero without the
cave
because uh you don't you don't have to
uh
save people you don't have to uh
uh be in a war you don't have to go to
the space like uh
uh ben aldries or
uh or people like that
or kobe bryant
you can do the small things for a
society
and you will be uh you'll be the
hero without the cave would be a
question for you
because because i know the the concept
of autism is on your mind because you're
putting six hours a day for three years
back to back to back and you're
you said you have to stop loving
yourself because you got to love your
daughter your baby
what do you think about vaccine i didn't
even know the question what do you think
about vaccine because
somebody like you as a father you've
probably done a lot of research
what are your thoughts when you think
about vaccines uh
let uh you you are talking about vaccine
uh when she was
two years old yes she was a big
colleague no no
no no not kobe before okay okay when she
was two years old
i have to be i have to be straight even
you
cut the interview if you know what i
mean no no go for it if you ask me
if you ask me it's a [ __ ]
sorry on my language but it's really
really
[ __ ] this i believe in science
because i i i wasn't on 60
what was the year when the apollo 13
come to the moon uh 66 or 67 something
like that
someone rounder yes yes okay okay
it's it's the same thing because i
wasn't
on the moon to see did they or did they
not
cross the moon okay but i believe in
science
if science says there is no connection
between
vaccine and autism i believe in science
because i know nothing about it but if i
if i have a doubt of everything
where where i am if you know what i mean
it's same thing with tesla tesla
invented
electricity okay but i i wasn't born
during the tesla
and i can say no it's it's it's a guard
will but it's not
tesla invented edison invented barely
invented
the phone and things like that okay
and i have to believe in a sign in that
case
there is lots and lots of researching
that they
decided and they made conclusion
that vaccine has nothing to do with the
autism in fact my daughter sasha
she was not vaccined and there is still
uh autism
do you have any other proof from me i
allowed you to to say i have a problem
with boxism
vaccinating my kid and i don't want to
do it
it's your free will very interesting so
what you're saying is your daughter
never took any vaccines and she still is
autistic
right exactly only a few
only a few that but they have nothing to
do with the
with the with the autism uh
and the guy and the people who are
uh talking about uh vaccine and autism
they don't mention those kind of vaccine
they are mentioning
um five in one sixteen one seventeen one
if you know what i mean
now in the ten years time it will be ten
in one
but sasha didn't get it
exactly because she was her brain was
kind of damaged and they say
it's not allowed we are not sure what is
going to happen
but still she got autism
so there is no connection between in our
case between autism
i i think it's just a number
i think it's just a number it's just uh
one of one million uh especially if we
are talking about
uh vaccine against
covet there is a statistic if if one
million
are taking vaccine for uh
it doesn't have to be pfizer moderna
johnson and johnson
or whatever it is but if you're reading
any kind of uh
letter with some with some drugs
you will find lots of lots of things
that
you can do the harm right
you know what i mean very familiar with
the harm of drugs yes
absolutely okay okay and you will you
will find
lots of lots of things that it could be
wrong but it doesn't mean that you will
get it
if you know what i mean so what i'm
saying
uh like like any kind of
vaccine it's just a number
if we if we vaccine two or three
millions of people millions of people
and we have two or three uh
well bad experience it doesn't have to
stop what's in if you know what i mean
this is my opinion this is why this is
just
uh we know nothing about no the reason
why
the reason why i asked you is because
you i mean
we're supposed to talk about 24 minutes
and 37 seconds
and we talk about autism the reason why
we talk autism is because
one of the biggest parts of your
motivation in your life is your daughter
your daughter motivates you so for me i
was curious you know because you went
that angle
i was curious to know what you thought
about vaccine that's very uh
helpful for you to share that with us
but let's go on to your time
let's go on to your time buddha tell me
this seven years ago
when you first started diving seven
years ago i watched the video with you
and with the you know with the with the
the
mermaid thing on your leg yeah
and you did three laps under the water
right you went back and forth underwater
three laps yes this is my first
150 meters seven years ago
seven years ago how long could you keep
your breath underwater
not today but seven years ago uh
two and a half minutes so you went from
two and a half minutes to 24 minutes
that's right you uh you have to
understand
uh seven years ago i was a
smoker as well i did the three packs
of marlboro sorry for uh say
the name of the cigarette uh three packs
a cigarette a day and one day one day i
asked my coach
am i going to be a better because i'm
not competing just to compete
i want to compete to be the best if you
want to be if you you and i we can
compete
how long you will uh keep your mouth
shut
and i will win i will try to
for me everything is competing i mean
not in a
you know in a in a bad way if you know
whatever sure
i i i want to i want to compete
if i lose i lose if i win i suppose
i i'm going to meet what is your
birthday i know you said you're 56 but
15 15 15 of august focus got it
interesting and you're super competitive
so you're smoking three packs of
cigarettes a day
yeah i ask you michael say to me my
coach said to me
okay if you stop
smoking now for the first year you will
have a
worse result than now do you know why
because of co2 cigarettes
makes you to uh make
co2 easier because you are smoking
you are making that kind of uh poison in
yourself
already okay but when you stop
smoking your kind of your
your amount of oxygen you'll take much
higher than now and i said to myself
okay what's my vision when i was a kid
i was trying to do something special to
go
to die with some respectable result in
any area could be a
cooking could be sport could be
amount of girls that i have been if you
know what i mean
and now we come to the point that i'm
the guy at this moment
with 56 years old and no one can beat me
at this moment
well don't i have to be modest but
at this at this point try if you can
try to beat me because i have more space
than you know because i'm doing like
bubka
i was ready for 28 minutes
in sisak i was ready for 28 minutes my
goal
is half an hour which i know that
it's impossible for 99.9
free divers in the world i don't know
how it happens but it happens
first of all i train seven days a week
never stop i have no time for rest
because i'm 56 if you know what i mean
when you are 20 you you have uh
schedule two days of training one day
rest two days of training one day's
rest now when i when you're 56
you don't have a time tell me why right
why do you not have time
because you are 56 in two years time
but but training wise my body
will never accept this
two years from now if you know what i
mean it will be much
harder it uh it would be uh
uh many kind of disease i could have in
two years if you don't know what i mean
with my eyes with my blood pressure with
my uh
with lots of lots or lots of things so i
don't have
too much time in front of me maybe two
years
in a competitive way to be
one of the three or four the best free
divers in the world
and that's my goal in two years time
what i did
that would be that would be top and i
will say okay
i gave you homework it's a half an hour
see you in a 30 or 40 years and you will
still
sorry but that's that's that's my vision
of uh
of of of sport i know maybe when you
when you're in it when i was watching
you you were doing a breathing exercise
right before you were you were breathing
and then they put the bubble you know
the water coming up below you and then
you put the thing on your nose and you
went in what what's the exercise you're
doing right before what is that exercise
okay i will tell you 90
of my i will keep it for myself ten
percent is it
is it fair for you yes it's okay yeah
yeah because there is a lot of guy
who are better than me who are more
most famous than me and they were trying
in the last two years
to break my record which was
24 11 and
they didn't succeed so i have special
preparing if you know what i mean i
found myself in
some kind of i'm not doing uh meditation
i'm not doing yoga it's just my
let's say strong will and i found myself
okay five breathe one easier
five deep breed one easier five
i don't want to say how many of them i
i did it and then i said okay
now it's time uh dead or alive
uh it was earthquake during my attempt
small
but it was earthquake
and i said to my coach i'll kill you
if you take me out why i will
i will explain why because the people in
that area
are suffering for 10 15
20 35 earthquakes
a day it's just this one
earthquake during my attempt if you're
taking me out
trust me look at me in the eyes i will
kill you
because i have no uh i have no
uh i can't
do to those people they are waiting
outside for me
to break guinness record only
if there is no water because
everything's crushed
then say okay buddha go out because
there is no water around you
but otherwise and it was small i can
feel it
i was feeling and i said like this no no
no no way
don't don't get me out so the
the most important thing i have
the biggest uh uh
wish to make that kind of
that kind of guinness record because
i i'm always thinking about the kids
not about myself i'm just their voice if
you know what i mean
i can't help them on the other way if
so if i make 24
37 and it's going to be guinness
look at this i am in front of you you
are you you are legend
and how how i get to you if i
didn't do guinness record
am i right now it gives me uh
a possibility to say uh
autistic kids are not it's not illness
it's just matter of state
if you know what i mean they are not
evil
if they are uh shaking their self
don't look at like them uh like they are
some kind of disease uh turn around your
head
please try to help them because they are
not doing in purpose
it's just the brain if you know what i
mean and it's not
it's not curable it's a state for the
rest of their life
and on us it's a matter of how
we can make the life easier
that's the main point and
at the end of the my life you have a
mirror
and you will say i get my best there is
the
beautiful sentence it's my favorite
sentence
in a movie resting
uh private uh
private rhyme yes saving private ryan
sorry sorry
and the last scene the last scene tom
hanks
said to matt damon do you remember yeah
last sentence
make it count make it count or something
uh deserve it
deserve it yeah and he asked his wife at
the end of the movie
and that's right this is the the whole
point of my life deserve it
i i i'm always you know like this
it's already makes me uh cry
but this is my motto deserve it
you came to this earth you you don't
have to be tesla
you don't have to be armstrong on the
moon
you don't have to be uh musk you don't
have to be
the last president before
obama now this one uh obama you don't
have to be obama
which i'm not approved for his uh
awareness for a piece i think
other guys deserve it more than him
because
i expected much i'm his friend don't get
me wrong
don't get me wrong i expected much more
from him
he's still my favorite uh president
but i'm kind of kind of disappointed
because he has
such a great opportunity to make the
world
better i thought for sure you would have
said trump is your favorite
for sure i thought you love donald trump
no
way no way are you kidding
me i'm kidding we of course i'm kidding
i know your story because
no no i i don't want to say any any
wrong word about the trump because
he he was your president and you have to
respect that
yes there is 300 million people in
waters in america am i right
and if you take 72 millions of people
you have to respect them on this on the
other way
72 millions croatia has only four
come on seven to two millions they say
we want trump for a president
and you have to respect them you can't
say they are all stupid
don't get me wrong it's my opinion it's
my opinion
i i don't uh uh agree with my
ex-president
in croatia but i say
okay he's my president and i have to
follow their rules if you know what i
mean i was
you know i i elected i was
i never i never missed any kind of
election
i always go because i think it's your
duty to make a cross for
one person or the other it's your duty
and it has to be obligation brother guys
i gotta tell you
i gotta tell you this interview i
thought we were going to have a
10-minute interview by you doing 24
minutes and 33 or 37 seconds
you are a very deep man you have a lot
of deep
convictions and ideas i want to ask you
one question though
that because you also seem like you have
a very fun side to you there's a there's
a fun
side because you were recognized at one
point as the top 500 most handsome man
in the world
and you did some calculations on that oh
my god
you really did your homework no no yes
yes i really think that when when you
are 20
when you are 20 and you are looking kind
of
good not not just scans well
you have you have talk you you could you
could
uh you can drink a lot uh you are
looking handsome
you are tall you are playing basketball
and uh
what else i i it was one night when i
was
i said to my next wife i said
let me let me tell you what i think
about myself and
i i was calculating it's a wrong
calculation
but i still got the 500 and at that
point i was in the same line
with brad pitt who is a
really handsome guy you know oh and i
said
so what brad pitt buddha then uh
matthew montgomery or what's his name
the story
on my parents transition
great uh paul newman
accept his his eyes because
his he has his eyes like uh
like like a lake if you know what i mean
his his eyes are
well known
yeah yeah he was a great looking man i
mean when
every time i i see paul human i'm
pregnant
if you know what i mean
well i have to tell you i mean i mean
i'm straight don't get me wrong but you
can't say
that angelina jolie is not a
good-looking woman
it's it's it's a matter of taste okay we
can uh
argue do we have do we like bigger
breasts
small breasts uh big ass
smallest but the beauty is the beauty
am i right okay so so you you want them
bragged about the fact that uh nightlife
in uh
zagreb is better than london why is
night life better over there than london
well i i'll tell you the truth i was in
london
and i had some money really
i really had some money because i earned
him a lot because i was a stuntman
here in croatia and i earned some money
and uh at one point of my life i said
okay i'm not happy here i want to
explore and i went to the first
office where they are selling a ticket
and i said
what is the first flight from zagreb
i was hoping it's going to be amsterdam
and they say the first flight is
tomorrow morning
london and i said okay i'll buy it
and i went to london the first 10 year
days
i was thinking that i was learning
completely different language than
they are talking in london i didn't i
didn't understand a word they are
talking
i go there you go there infinitive
everything was infinite and i was
thinking
oh my god where i am if you know what i
mean so
uh you know in a one year time
i said to myself no i'm not happy here
because the tube it's closed at 11
p.m okay there is no traffic with the
tube
there is no taxi they are driving on the
left side of the road which is
completely
no sense come on the the rest of the
world we are driving on the right side
so you are clever because you have a
queen and you are driving on the left
side on the road it's it's completely
nonsense and uh the third thing
uh the pubs are closing at 11 o'clock
the pubs if you are talking about the
pups local pubs in any area you know
that
that much better than i am so in
croatia in zagreb pubs are working
24 hours a day and uh when i was with my
girlfriend i said i'm going to buy a
newspaper
and i come back after three days with
the gypsies on uh
behind me they are they are they are
playing violins if you know what i mean
it would never happen in in london and i
was
and i said to myself no it's a good area
for me
i don't feel comfortable really i don't
think comfortable because
they are mixed they are always saying oh
croatia is part of russia come on
come on you have to know the geography
do you understand my point i know lots
of shakespeare
i know lots of your sports guys i know
lots of your history
i know who is your uh prime minister at
the moment
and you still think that croatia is part
of russia come on
you're stupid i'm talking about the
people
that i'm dealing with yeah
that kind of by the way i i i went to uh
uh i went to
my favorite place i went to 12 13 year
13 years ago now
it's been 13 years i went to dubrovnik i
had an incredible time in dubrovnik
and then last year we went to split two
years ago we went to split and
two years ago we went to split pre-kobe
we had a great time when i went to
dubrovnik
when you get off the boat the ship you
go in there's a uh
thai store kravate there's a kravati
store that they had
and both there and in split they told me
that
croatia invented the thai not france
is that that's right like a pen
like a pen pen is a croatian uh
invention croatian guy yes yes
yes yes uh crud the guy named
it's a shame on me that i don't know his
name
but uh he invented the the tithe
really really it's it's uh tesla's
coming from uh
croatia but he's a mixed he's half
server half croatian
but now he ended as uh american citizen
which is the the best thing he ever did
because
otherwise we will kill each other
we want to make them his creation or his
serve
but the main thing is uh
first of all uh it was the summer when
you came to
dubernik am i right it's a wrong
decision
because it was so crowded and you can't
see a thing
next time if you come to dubai rick go
during the spring or
autumn or winter otherwise
there is a such a crowded place you
can't enjoy in that
that's my that's my advice split also
because it's a traffic place for uh
fairies to go to other islands
near to split so uh
if you had a touristic guide uh
there is not much you can see if you
know what i mean because it's a
very crowded place at that time of year
we had a good time yeah we went over
there to uh
and and we were walking around with an
old girlfriend of mine
and we went to it was oh seven it had to
be old seven oh seven is what it was
and we're walking we're like let's go to
a beach and we go to this one beach and
just like you what you used to like to
do back in the days
everybody was naked so now it makes
sense
there's a lot of nude beaches in croatia
oh yes oh yes
we accepted that because uh
uh the french guys uh and french
tourists uh which they started to come
to croatia
30 years ago they invented topless first
of all
topless and then uh nudity and we
accepted that
like uh it's a normal thing we have no
problem
like you in america if you are wearing
something uh
appropriate that uh some kind of police
beach police
will come no no no please don't don't
make
i i think it's puritism if you don't if
you understand me
it's uh i don't agree with that don't
get me wrong
america is a it's a great country but
some things
i don't agree with them if you know what
i mean
well buddha i gotta tell you i had a
really good time with you i'm glad you
were able to uh be a guest here on
valuetainment to share your story both
on you the the part that you inspired me
the most was the following you said i
went and did 24-37 because
this gives me the chance to tell the
story of what my passion is which is
autism
your daughter your desire to make the
world a better place and hopefully
people have uh heard that message and
we're inspired by you just as much as i
was inspired by you
once again thank you so much for being a
guest on valentine's day thank you
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much take care
you got to have some deep convictions to
be able to handle that kind of pain like
you
know a man like him you heard about his
kid you know how much he loves his
country the convictions he has he kept
using the word tesla tesla tesla
because tesla was half croatian but uh
the kind of a guy i would love to go
have a drink with just sit down and have
dinner with him to hear the story you
can tell
how fascinating of a guy he is but i'm
curious to know what you took away from
it comment below also if you enjoyed
this video
of him breaking a world record you would
also enjoy the interview i did with nick
wallenda when he
was walking on a wire across some crazy
places if you've never seen this
it's an insane one as well as the other
one akins
who jumped out of a plane free diving
jumped out of a plane no parachute
into a net broke the world record as
well if you like these types of
interviews
click on either one of these regardless
of whichever one you watch have a great
day everybody take care bye
you